en mexico las clases presenciales para
cerca de 30 millones de estudiantes de
distintos niveles fueron suspendidas el
23 de marzo de 2020 en aquel entonces el
número de contagios rondaban los 367
casos confirmados casi un año después y
aun sin tener plenamente controlada la
pandemia alumnos del estado de jalisco
volvieron a las aulas el retorno se
produce en medio de un riguroso plan
desarrollado por la secretaria de
educación del estado de jalisco y hoy
arrancamos dos acciones la primera tiene
que ver con los grupos de acompañamiento
académico que son grupos como ustedes
pudieron constatar hasta de nueve
alumnos son grupos que hemos informado
la estructura educativa se pueden
gestionar de manera muy flexible están
diseñados para no solo apoyar a los
alumnos en su estudio sobre todo
aquellos alumnos que han tenido una
mayor dificultad jalisco es uno de los
20 estados mexicanos que se encuentran
en amarillo en el llamado semáforo
epidemiológico y registró un acumulado
de 222 mil 324 contagios según datos
oficiales la nación que fue la primera
latinoamericana en empezar a vacunar
aplicado más de dos millones y medio de
dosis para el día de hoy tenemos pues un
reporte de 567 mil 338 segundas dosis
que se estarían habrían aplicado es
decir ya dosis completas esquemas
completos lo cual se traduce obviamente
también en trabajadores de la salud que
en las próximas dos semanas dado que ya
tienen las dos dosis completas estarían
alcanzando obviamente la protección otro
paso de méxico hacia el regreso a la
normalidad fue la vuelta a las salas de
cine y aunque no se permitirá un aforo
total se trata de un alivio para la
industria que de acuerdo con la cámara
nacional de cine registró una caída de
sus ingresos del 80,6 por ciento en 2020
debido a la pandemia